And Eric, do we have clarity tonight,...
…on exactly how monkeypox is being spread and apparently so quickly?
Yeah, you know, there is discussion that it's sexually transmitted,...
…but obviously traditionally with monkeypox,...
…you also can have direct contact with scabs, with bodily fluids,...
…it's well known.
And CDC has acknowledged, as theoretically possible,...
…that it is aerosol, airborne.
And therefore, they recommend you take precautions,...
…against aerosol transmission until we learn more.
Because we have to have the humility,...
...to know that, you know, many, two years ago,...
…we said, "Oh, it's just the flu" for COVID.
"Oh, it wasn't airborne."
But did turn out to be airborne.
It did turn out to have lots of reinfection potential,...
…and it wasn't just the flu.
So, with especially new virus, potentially,...
…a new version of this virus, potentially with 50 mutations,...
...we have to be extra precautious until we learn more.
And in some countries,...
…and I'm talking about right here in Germany as well,...
…there are no recommendations right now,...
...in terms of what people should do regarding monkeypox.
What would your recommendation be tonight?
Well, I think, first of all, be very careful about any close contact,...
...so, definitely wash your hands.
And you know what?
Masking may have a double benefit,...
…against both COVID and potentially monkeypox,...
…if this theoretically airborne is true.
It's supported by experimental evidence as well.
So, we should really take the same precautions as COVID.